[Musica]
sono non è finita via cappello
macchietta macchietta dov'è la mia
barchetta non ricordo la formata farà
tariffa pagata e questo è un problema
bacchetta vieni fuori
sarà perché ho mangiato la bacchetta po
mi appare una polpetta anche il cappello
adesso via merlo casa mia
questi pazzi ma il loro corbetta che una
bacchetta
eccola qui lo sapevo alla fine vela
sopra ricordata la formula adesso visto
che questo mio cappello cade sempre
bacchetta pomello cambiamo il cappello e
finalmente ho anche il cappello ad ora
che ho la bacchetta e anche il cappello
ho bisogno solo dei miei utensili per
svolgere la mia condizione di per grande
mago e così farò la mia prima
maledizione nel mio grande calderone e
potrei stupirvi con altre mille magie
anche se qui non c'è nessuno ma farò
apparire il secondo calderone e quindi
il terzo calderone per finire anche il 4
camper o e regala abbiamo il tutto e tu
chi saresti sono un mago un mago molto
potente e sono qui per cercare gli
ingredienti per le mie emozioni
come puoi vedere tu n a caso qualche idf
e pulsioni veramente gli unici
ingredienti che ho qua sono gli
ingredienti per lo slime
ma di certo non li do uno sconosciuto
come te e poi come hai fatto ad arrivare
qui in camera mia non sono un mago
potente e possa apparire dove voglio
ma che cos'è questo slime è qualcosa di
magico
facciamo così se io ti dico queste
lustra il metodo anche gli ingredienti
troppo può insegnarmi apre una magia o
qualcosa del genere qualcosa da maghi
non posso non posso perché non hai una
bacchetta ma quello che posso fare
invece a regalarti una pozione magica
affare fatto non so cosa sia questa
pozione magica ma sicuramente molto
interessante quindi ok
affare fatto ok signor mago io mi siedo
qui aspetto questa pozione magica ma che
cosa fa questa pozione però non me l'hai
mica detto comici pensare dunque a e
nominato gli slime prima non è vero
sì posso farti una pozione che ti aiuti
a creare diciamo uno slime magico ok non
so come sia nel magico ma va bene mi
coesis molto bene ho già tutto qui nella
capoccia bene iniziamo subito con i
glitter e un po di sapienza ci vorrà
tanta pazienza
foglie di prezzemolo bacche di alloro e
ci aggiungo anche un po di pomodoro con
la sapienza di un mago potente stai
attenta per sempre
che sapore sublime che profumo signori
sta creando una zuppa con una pozione
impassibili il con prezzemolo vido
verificare amor nel secondo voi questo
sta bollendo purtroppo è con la sapienza
di questo mago potente ora di baby anche
questo ingrediente questo calderone
l'assessore contrade vagoni e tutto poco
troppo poco 1 posto di emozioni non so
più che fare e meglio sentendo
raffreddare e franca e la pozione mia
cara è qui pronto per te ti rimane solo
una cosa da fare molto importante cosa
bella ovviamente è qui pronta e la passa
terra brucia ok baby baby baby dai beni
per i vetri bolle ok baby forza successo
venne tolta brava ancora del veer la
bella volta capito abbastanza degli
altri per te non funzionerà che buona
buonissima deliziosa devo dire la zuppa
più buona che ho mai mangiato nella mia
vita
hai visto allora a che pro fuoco certo
che mi dovrebbe fare effetto tra
pochissimi secondi quindi mettiti pure
comoda e aspettiamo pazientemente questo
cappello non se ne può più
dovrò fare anche una mozione per terra
beh ma non succede niente che cosa devo
fare ora con questa pozione dovrebbe
avere effetto subito no solo prurito
[Musica]
dovessero un effetto collaterale della
funzione primo non ti preoccupare
passera e sono piccolo prurito che
l'importante è che passi
devo smettere di grattarmi altrimenti mi
farò un male metto la mano così buffa
che prurito
[Musica]
signor mago frey che cos'è questa
domanda è che cosa ci fa sulla mia mano
più che cosa è successo alla mia mano
questa è un'ottima domanda non saprei
proprio no
anche l'altra mano mi prude vuol dire
che mi sto trasformando questo è molto
strano ma io non ho fatto mi dà una
pozione polisucco ma che cosa hai
combinato
non ci pensare un attimino dammi
controllare cosa avremmo sbagliato qui
ma non è che per caso c'è qualcun altro
in questa stanza o in questa casa il mio
cane berlino anzi è proprio in nome di
un mago lo sapevi berlino ma ognuno
ora capisco tutto probabilmente un peso
del tuo cane sarà accaduto in uno dei
miei calderoni ne avrà rovinato la mia
mozione per sempre
quindi è caduto per la pozione io lo
vedo informerò in un cane o in un lupo
non soffrire io potrei cominciare ad
andare intanto io tornerei a casa mia
così allora se tu hai bevuto la pozione
con il velo del tuo cane merlino che è
trasformato in un lupo ma anche un
potenziale lupo mannaro allora dunque la
mia mozione era una pozione per uno
slide magico quello che potresti fare
secondo me ci sono pochissime le
possibilità ma vale la pena provarle e
provare a trovare in tutti gli
ingredienti slime è fare uno slide
magari c'è una piccolissima possibilità
che tutti
salva piccolissima eh sì perché altri
ghetti e dovrai semplicemente lupo
andata per sempre è facile no un tempo
pochissimo devi sbrigarti travolse fuori
in giardino ma mi faccia un male l'altra
mano come faccio a fare lo slime con le
zampe è per questo che ti devi sbrigarti
ok ragazzi sbrighiamo se troviamo tutti
gli ingredienti slime le avventure di
testo non finiscano mai mi raccomando
lasciate un bel mi piace e se questo
video raggiunge il 40 mila voli fials e
faremo tornare il mago anche se non so
se vi conviene visto com'è andata questa
volta la paletta troviamo già trovato
oniricamente lan tattico uno sforzo qua
devo cercare gli altri a destra e viola
delle lenti il bicarbonato da vuoi dire
che sta andando bene per fortuna il
problema è che l'altra mano mi sta dando
molto prurito e anche i piedi e quindi
ho paura che stia avvenendo la
trasformazione e non troppo gli altri
ingredienti non troppo l'associazione
per niente il bicarbonato
ragazzi ho trovato tutto ecco qua
andiamo a portarli subito al mago e
speriamo che funzioni questo contro
incantesimo signor mago ecco li ho
trovati tutti il futuro dai sbrighiamocì
dirmi subito che cosa devo fare
come devo fare bene e molto bene hai
raccolto tutti gli indirizzi vuol dire
svegliamoci
potevo fare ora beh direi di cominciare
a pensare alla ceretta molto divertente
ma io non intendevo la mano ammette però
i piedi tv cosa devo fare non so che
devo studiare allora i quali in quale
padella non un paio di telecamere
comincia molto male se sbagli i nomi
visto che funzioni purtroppo non c'era
tantissima accordo ma funzionerà lo
stesso spero di sì sbrigarmi prurito ti
conviene sbrigarsi mia cara altrimenti
anche l'altra mano dimetterà famosissima
la donna non faccia ora catturava lupo
questo è il problema non riusciremo mai
a da pensare lo slime di non prenderlo
in mano quale sarà la prossima cosa a
trasformarsi mi spunta era una coda ad
aprire questa cosa non è che potresti
aiutarmi magari signor ma col impegnato
con la mia bacchetta che forse può
bastare io proverò mette non poco la mia
magia
devo ancora del giallo ma come faccio
con queste varie difficilissimo torino
con i pacchetti sembra una schifezza
credo che siamo questa palette queste
zampe proviamo ad aggiungere hawks ne ho
messo troppo ma forse almeno si attiverà
velocemente forse si articola tu guarda
guarda è pronto lo so fa schifo e
arrendevoli portate che sia un sito come
ma ora ma davvero orribile devo dire ora
come cosa che cosa devo fare come faccio
a tornare normale devo fare un
incantesimo qui nel calderone aspetto
secondo sbrigativi barboni ma chi piedi
è tutto tornato come prima
red eye sciolto la maledizione della
pozione polisucco non in vico esatto o
il giusto per bel momento di andare
bombara bel bebè
bel ragazzo siamo riusciti a vincere
anche questa sfida contro il mago
cattivo mi raccomando lasciate mi piace
sono mi seguite ancora su instagram
andati a seguirmi il nome anita stories
e ora vi lascio qua 4 caselline su cui
cliccare per vedere i miei altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite e buona
visione
[Musica]